des centaines de familles sont donc
maintenant en des des mots réconfortants
pour les familles qui vivent un deuil en
lien avec la pandémie
un processus de deuil qui est d'ailleurs
en pleine transformation
depuis le 16 mars je voudrais que tout
ce qu'on considère est un événement
funérailles traditionnelles au sens au
sens de nos opérations a été suspendus
et reportés
la grand maman de françoise boissinot
est décédé dans les derniers jours de
l'éco vite 19 ses funérailles une
pourront être célébrée au moment prévu
la famille devra attendre avant de bien
vivre son deuil
c'est ce que la célébration va être
retardé à après les mesures de
confinement
c'est sûr que en attendant on fait des
téléphones à toute la famille à cette
coopérative funéraire des changements
ont été apportés pour respecter les
mesures de distanciation sociale la
famille proche seulement est autorisée
une décision difficile vu l'importance
d'un dernier adieu entouré de ses
proches
ils peuvent quand même rendre un dernier
hommage pour une célébration c'est pas
un rituel
ça fait un peu penser à l'activité
d'identification l'année quelques
minutes une maisonnée à la fois dans une
pièce qui est adjacent dans notre
laboratoire et la famille peut se
recueillir sur la dépouille
une dernière fois une compresse est
difficile pour les endeuillés c'est
extrêmement difficile je ne répète on
peut pas mettre un oeil sur pauvres chez
lépine cloutier atoch on met à la
disposition des proches des outils
numériques
une solution qui est bien accueillie on
va donc capter la salle ou à lui les
rituels funéraires pour que les gens à
l'extérieur peut se connecter avec leurs
appareils mobiles leur ordinateur donc
ça permet ces gens là et c'est pour ces
points remplacement idéal mais c'est
mieux que de ne rien avoir du tout au
québec environ 180 personnes décèdent
chaque jour et même si toute la province
est sur pause les proches de ses défunts
devront passer à travers une autre
grande tragédie leur deuil
il s'y fait l'ex morissette boulud radio
canada à québec